a U.S House committee has released six
years of Donald Trump's tax returns the
former president fought for years to
keep them secret last week the Democrat
controlled house Ways and Means
Committee Moda 2 released Trump's tax
records from 2015 to 2020 they're likely
to provide New Revelations about his
finances Trump was the first
presidential candidate in decades who
refused to release his tax records the
Republicans are about to take control of
the House of Representatives
our correspondent Stefan Siemens has
more from Washington so Stefan what do
these documents tell us about Donald
Trump
you're all uh reset button first so this
is a ongoing's trial for seven years why
because Donald Trump was the only and
first president who refused to make his
tax records public this is something U.S
presidents or candidates for U.S
presidents and then when they are
heading into the final election fight
with another Contender one that is
um doing normally they release their tax
records he did not he fought it all the
way the Supreme Court gave finally
a clear way to do this and now there you
have it and let me just tell you the
overall first impression is remember
when he said once in a in a debate with
Hillary Clinton that if he doesn't pay
taxes that just makes him smart well it
seemed to be not stupid when it comes to
paying taxes because for example in 2017
his income tax was
750 750
in 2018 and 19 a little more 1.1 million
dollars and in 2020 here you go zero
dollars in income tax at the same time
of course Donald Trump always said he is
very rich and you know and that also
shows in his uh tax returns and this is
what is public here and let me say uh
just for all those who think everything
is public though now those tax returns
are heavily redacted so private
information States private Social
Security numbers Etc but for example in
2015 Donald Trump uh claimed 105 million
dollars in losses and put this on the
next year and so on every year uh
basically for the IRS he was making no
money at all hence no income taxes hmm
well I guess it'll take a while to
really sift through all that information
it's been quite a year for Trump uh talk
talk us through the investigations he's
currently facing Stefan
yes it hasn't been a good year for
Donald Trump and it comes to those
investigations around and there's four
major investigations one since of course
the investigation federal investigation
into Mar elago the Mar-A-Lago
investigation what was that president
took uh classified documents from the
white house it looks like and stored
them in his uh private residence
Mar-A-Lago in Florida and of course also
with this comes a obstruction
investigation did he lie and did he
obstruct or did others lie for him and
he lied of what he has what he doesn't
have and where he put it that's still
ongoing second one federal investigation
also is the January 6
investigation not the committee in the
in the in the House of Representatives
that's a different thing but there is a
federal investigation into if
there were broader efforts by the
president and others in his Circle to
influence the results of the 2020
elections and with this number three
very important the one in Georgia we all
remember the phone call or the tape of
the phone call Donald Trump made that
he's looking for 11 000 votes in Georgia
and please somebody bring him 11 000
votes so he can win this state well that
didn't happen it was taped and of course
there's a criminal investigation in
Georgia because of this against him and
others and then there is two more
two more let's say one big one but
there's actually two uh against him a
civil
investigation not a criminal
investigation from the attorney general
in New York as well as a investigation
that's criminal again again against the
Trump organization and Trump Foundation
one of them already has results that was
from the Manhattan district attorney and
people uh were fined and looking at jail
time for mischievous and and things they
did with the Trump organization